have you still got the post on your
phone yeah yeah can we see it they're my
words and I stick by
them wag at christe starts today at the
high court fellow Wags and former
friends embroiled in a around
someone on my personal account was
informing the Sun newspaper of my priv
posts and stories I thought I'm going to
do something about it
this is a detective story you never find
the person responsible with a Smoking
Gun in her hand she was going to lose a
trial I needed evidence I had to set a
trap never in a million years would I
have said oh you just go on your
Instagram settings you upload fake
stories what you done here really been
War of the W I'd never imagined being in
illegal battle the medor attention was
off the SC
that's a path
there I had a message of Rebecca saying
what is this I replied you know what
this
is it was just constantly on your mind
she struggled and she was obsessed I was
are you okay Dad said just not you
anymore this is going to be toal
Mayhem don't play games where a g who
can play
better colen Rooney the real waga
[Music]
story